(audience applauding)
- I have a TV show!
- I know!
- And you're on it!
- It's insane actually.
- It's so crazy.
I am so excited to see,
we never get to see each other really
'cause we both work so hard but,
our kids are really close friends,
they always wonder where Dash
and Dylan are and I'm like,
they're in a different state.
- It's amazing because
my kids have no reference
for the fact that she is so famous,
- They think I'm River's mom.
- And so they,
they think River's mom,
that's who Kelly is
and when we were doing
Songland on the lot here,
there's pictures of you everywhere
(laughing)
and our kids would just be
like, oh, there's River's mom.
Why is River's mom's picture everywhere
and where is yours?
- [Kelly] And where is yours? (laughing)
That's so your kids!
- Yeah,
and I was wondering the same thing.
(laughing)
- Are you musical at all?
- I was the one white
person, of two white people
in a black gospel musical on Broadway.
- Woa.
- So, that means yes.
- How did that happen?
- I do sing a little bit
but I didn't have a gospel song
for my audition so I sang
"Suddenly Seymour" from
Little Shop of Horrors,
I still got the job.
- I love that song.
- That's amazing.
Here's another thing that's amazing,
you're always up for, I love that my crew
who was researching you,
like he's up for an award,
I'm like he's always up for awards.
- I love trophies.
(exuberant laughing)
I'm sorry,
- That is so Texas.
- When people call this stuff,
it is so Texas.
- I actually don't care, man.
- And I know you really don't.
- I know.
- And people will say like, you know,
it's nice to be nominated.
I'm like, give me the trophy.
(loud laughing)
If you really don't care,
if it really doesn't matter to you,
if it's just good to be
nominated, I'll take it.
(laughing)
- I will take that burden for you.
- Right.
- No but you are, is it song
of the year for the CMA's?
- Yes.
- You tied a record too?
(loud cheering and applause)
Thank you.
- [Kelly] Is it Rainbow?
- It's for Rainbow, for Kasey
Musgrave's and actually,
one of my heroes, Alan
Jackson, held the record
for most nominations for song of the year
and I just tied that record.
Seven songs in seven years.
(loud cheering and applause)
- That's so incredible.
- I am just like, try not to
diminish those kind of things
like not do the whole, you know,
when we're given compliments
or when people say,
god, this is amazing,
we're so drawn to go,
oh you know, well we'll see.
I mean, how did that happen?
I'm trying to say you
know what, it is amazing.
I am so blessed and so
truly honored to get to do
what I love and I know
how unusual that is.
- And how hard you had to work to get it.
- That's exactly right so I do,
I just try to go thank
you, I am a bad ass.
(laughing)
- And I know your story, yes,
and I do, I know your story
for all of those people
out there thinking that oh my gosh,
it's never gonna happen,
it will happen.
You stick with it, dude you
were like living in your car,
I feel like at one point in (mumbles),
you were doing like odd jobs.
- I was sleeping on my sister's couch.
I had been in Nashville at
that point for 14 years,
trying to get a song
recorded and in and out,
I moved out here for a while.
Actually, when Kelly won American Idol,
I had friends that knew her
and I became so obsessed
with if I could just meet Kelly Clarkson,
I could give her a song.
And it would always happen
where they would always
hang out without me, and
it wasn't intentional,
but then I was positive it was.
(laughing)
- Like, keep him away from her.
- I was so certain that they were like,
do not bring him around Kelly.
And maybe they were, I mean, I don't know
but the truth is--
- No they weren't, they
were all raving about you
and you kept trying to get--
- Then you came to a
show where we had to sit,
you had to sit in little kid chairs.
- In Dallas, yeah.
- In Dallas
It was like a library.
- I was so excited,
you were so magical.
You're so great at what you do.
- Thank you.
- You are such a great storyteller,
which is why have over 40 number one's.
(loud clapping and cheering)
- I need these people
with me, all the time.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I'm sure doing sitcoms and
having a crowd like respond
to you that way,
- Yeah, it is wonderful, yeah.
- Wow, yeah.
- They do in my head,
even if they're not here.
- [Shane] Me too.
(laughing)
- Like when people don't like what I said,
just filter it, that was
amazing and so prolific.
(laughing)
So let's talk about Songland though,
because I remember when
this idea first came up,
the executive producer Audrey
was telling me about it,
and I thought god, this is
so genius, the whole idea
but for everybody that
doesn't know the concept
of Songland and didn't see it,
tell them what the concept is.
- Yeah, so we have an artist every week,
and unknown songwriters
are given the opportunity
to pitch songs to these
artists and it sounded,
in concept, like yeah,
that's an amazing idea
but who really wants to watch the process
that we all do behind the scenes?
- I do.
- Well, the truth is, it's been amazing
that people really want to see,
how did that song get to John Legend?
- And songs get there
in all different ways.
- Absolutely and sometimes
they go, I like that song
but it wouldn't work
for me because of this,
so you have the opportunity
right then to change it
for Macklemore and go, you know what?
Now that there's room for
that, how about try this?
- So cool.
- It really is like, it's a big leap.
You know, of all those
years you talked about me,
trying to make it in
songwriting, I thought
if I can get in the room
with Kelly Clarkson,
what's happening is these people,
- Are getting in the room with people.
- They're getting in the room with people
and so, it's really just
getting to see the process.
- And you're paying it forward.
- Yeah.
- You're so perfect for it.
(audience clapping)
Perfect.
Hilarious, talented.
- I love it.